28 year old southpaw eduardo rodriguez
on the bound last time around was
tuesday against the mets didn't get a
decision
in what amounted to a laborious four and
a third threw 92 pitches in that one and
had traffic on base throughout the
contest he's been very good against the
yankees as we profiled however in four
starts against new york this year
everything on the line tonight for
rodriguez
and le mayhew's aboard to start the ball
game eduardo rodriguez has had for
whatever reason a hard time retiring
lead off hitters in innings
great stop by dalby to bogarts for one
the double play
a terrific play here a much easier play
for a left-handed first baseman takes
his time the hard part is catching it
then the throw so with two gone and the
base is empty now it'll be aaron judge
and he's 2-2
swing and a miss he got him on a change
up away
on the bound for the yankees 28 year old
lefty jordan montgomery making start
number 29 this year looking to push his
record over 500 he said four assignments
against boston this year and while he
has not pitched badly in them he is owen
two to show for his efforts kicks and
delivers the pitch he swung on it
bounced up the middle and threw for a
base hit first ball swinging which he
likes to do attacking early at two
hopper
into center field just through the left
or second base
took the lead off man on for the red sox
kiki not wasting any time to get all
over this two seamer and the pitch is
swung out hit the air to left field not
deep gallow coming in he's got to play
and makes the catch in shallow left for
the second out two gone for xander who's
at 299 after going home for his last
eight
bogertz is tied up the one-two is cut
out of miss great cutter right in on the
end now where is giancarlo to lead it
off
slider put him away for the strikeout
his second of the game so you have him
thinking in you have them thinking in
and boom you take the slider
in the equalizer 2-1 deal and there's a
pop-up
right around the pitcher's mound eddie
pointing to the ball dalbeck comes in to
make the catch you get it i love the way
pitchers point to the ball there it is
it's up in the air
christian arroyo making his first start
since august 26th
oh look out shattered bat trouble that's
going to be a base hit i think the
shrapnel might have given montgomery a
little pause in his pursuit of the ball
understandably so and delivers a 2-2
strike three called on the inside corner
and eddie strikes out all three yankee
outs looking in the third he's got it
all going does he rod two gun bases
empty now for hunter renfro
and renfro bounces out of the mine a
great play by le mayhew long throw got
him lemayo stole the double away from
renfrow and then threw them out so one
two three
go the red sox into three no score and
now we're asking for time
joe west is trying to get the attention
of the grounds crew apparently there's
lights on some place yeah it's a fire
alarm things are hot here in fenway it's
going off in the in the luxury suites
around the perimeter of the park
the 1-0 is lined up the middle and
it goes off the glove of
arroyo into right center so there's a
base hit a chew out bases for stanton
stan hits the ball so hard except to
corral it at times almost takes erot's
head off and then it hits the bag so
here we go with jd martinez runners at
the corners nobody out jd has struggled
so much against montgomery the first
pitch high in the air into left field
gallow back onto the warning track in
front of the monster devers is tagging
he will come home the throw is wide
devers is safe one nothing red sox and a
jd sacrifice fly
excellent hitting from jd martinez and a
brutal mistake by gallow that ball needs
to come to second base instead it comes
to home play allowing boguards to
advance to second
through the first four innings of this
one seven strikeouts scattered three
base hits but very quickly the bases are
loaded here with nobody out in the fifth
a chopper for arroyo gets one himself
and there's the double play a run does
score the yankees have tied it at one a
piece but that's a trade that erod will
make any day so a run in with one out dj
le mayhew sanchez runner in third with a
run in and le mayhew flares the ball the
other way that's going to drive in the
go ahead run
throw comes in wildly to first
boston catches a break as it landed
right at vasquez and just a back breaker
rodriguez almost out of the inning
veteran hitter with a 2-2 count to
mayhew with the rbi single giving him
the lead at first
that he delivers and a swing and a miss
he did roger yeah
great pitch
sometimes you got to let the game roll a
little bit and see what montgomery has
is this the guy that we can depend in
october well this is a moment you want
to see him mature and get out of it
and the pitch is swung on and hit high
on the ear to right judge back he's on
the track he makes the catch right near
the wall he had a couple of steps to go
before the end of the boston bullpen the
long drive and judge went down there to
get it and montgomery was able to
squeeze himself out of the inning 2-0
iglesias has got to be choosy here he
swings and drives one into left field to
base it tying run as a board and it gets
past gallow iglesias is going to try it
and then stop at the last minute and
it's a good thing he did gallow the huge
arm in left well he looked like he was
thinking double out of the box oh he's
out at second base if he tries that two
and one that's 46 runs pat it in here's
the pitch
swing and a high pop up in a shallow
right center judges got the huge arm
tagging it third is iglesias he's gonna
test it judge's throw comes home not in
time foot first slide for iglesias and
the red sox have tied the game oh he
really was flying home i thought they
had a good chance to get him now kyle
schwarber comes up
two two pitches hit in the air out to
shallow left
gallow on the move for it oh boy oh no
he dropped it
throw into second base is in time to get
stormer but not before verdugo could
score and that's how the red sox have
taken the lead
yankees have been into two double plays
tonight three balls in a strike wade's
running throw down from arroyo is in
time to get him they got him a one-hop
throw nice play by bogart he kept the
tag on wade he might have fallen off the
bag vampire took a long look at it nick
lincoln rang him up a key play there and
it was strike two to le mayhew here it
comes
swinging a pop-up foul first base side
long run doll back he gets there and he
can't get it he didn't reach far enough
bobby thought he was a little closer to
the fence than in fact he was he kicks
he deals swing and a miss he got him oh
oh did he foul tip and it's dropped oh
was in and out of the mid of vasquez i'm
surprised that there's no challenge here
because he looked like he caught that
fair and square
and judge cashes in taking advantage of
the second and third chances
two runs score the yankees go back on
top stanton is the hitter
another
stantonian home run he swung the bat and
touched it off and it sailed high
majestically over the high wall over the
monster seats out into land zone the
third homer in as many games for
giancarlo so if they end the season in a
heat a dead tie for the wild card and
nobody else is involved then the wild
card game will be played here at fenway
park and chapman deals breaking ball
strike three ball game over yankees win
yankees
when
[Music]